always great to see you thanks for
joining us sorry i can't be with you
in the studio um how is christmas
looking for my viewers this morning
well good morning kay we're still in the
national lockdown measures as you know
but they will come to an end on the 2nd
of december that's a legal certainty
if they were going to be extended that
would have to be by a vote in parliament
it's our hope and expectation
that that won't be the case and that
people living in england will be able to
move back into
the tiered system there will be a review
that works undergoing as to what those
tiers
look like and how local areas will
go back into them that will very much
depend on the data
and we'll have to make decisions nearer
the end of the month once we've got the
most up-to-date information possible
to make those decisions so it's too
early to say which tiers people
will be able to go into but we all want
to see a significant easing of the
measures
in all parts of england at the beginning
of next month
how optimistic are you well i'm always
optimistic i hope that that's the case
that's the government's expectation
uh people have been working very hard
over the course of this month to
comply with the new rules and we are
starting to see
some positive data in most parts of
england there are some places where
the cases are continuing uh to rise but
there's positive news in many places
of course the data that we're seeing
today does have a lag time of a few
weeks so
we're only just if at all starting to
see the impact
of these new national measures and
that's why i think it's fair to say
we won't be able to make a definitive
call
until the end of the month because it
will be at that point where you can
really start to see
what the true impact has been of the
hard work that's happened over the
course of november
one of the options i suppose would be
this vaccine or
several vaccines that were we're hearing
about um the moderna one was the one
that was in the headlines yesterday did
the government order enough of that
well it's ordered 5 million doses which
is a lot of doses
and that also comes on top of the very
substantial number of doses we ordered
for the
pfizer project as well the vaccine task
force that we've got has done a
fantastic job over the course
of the last six months it's not poured
all of the uk's eggs in
one basket it's tried to pre-order as
many doses as it can
in as many of the more viable credible
options
that are available to us of course we
have our own homegrown
one with the oxford astrazeneca project
as well and
assuming that comes to fruition we'll
have a very significant supply from that
so
piecing them all together will give the
uk
a very good stock and will be one of the
best place countries
in the world but in each case it will be
some time before those vaccines are
fully tested for safety and go into
production and that varies by project
the fisa project does appear as if some
vaccinations
will be at our disposal for use by
members of the public before the end of
this year albeit perhaps only in
in small quantities the moderna project
very very good news from yesterday but
that won't actually be available to us
until the spring
so that's a bit more of a long-term
project by which time hopefully
some of the other vaccine programmes
like oxford
astrazeneca will be available as well
and by the spring only five million
doses that's what we ordered apparently
um
yesterday um in september
a broadcasting colleague of mine uh was
told by the government that we hadn't
bought modena because
the u.s wouldn't do a deal outside the
u.s
in august the eu bought 80 million doses
with the option to buy 80 million more
japan
and canada bought hundreds of millions
of more
doses was it a mistake in hindsight for
us not to have ordered more at the time
i don't know it's difficult to judge
from the information that i've seen
the uk is actually one of the best place
countries in the world because we have
bought vaccines from a number of
different
manufacturers if you look at the pfizer
project we've got i think 40 million
doses
you have to take two doses of that
vaccine so you're looking at
20 million individuals so that's a very
substantial proportion of the population
it looks as if we're well placed and the
real challenge will be
how quickly can we get these vaccines
and how can we roll it out in an
efficient
and sensible and fair way across the
country
i don't want to raise false hope because
it's going to take time uh both for
these
vaccines to be safety tested to be
produced and some of them are quite you
know
that's in itself is a complex process
and then for us to start
to roll them out but you know the last
two weeks have been a real source of
hope after
a very challenging period that next year
will
see us beginning to vaccinate the most
vulnerable people
key workers um and then the wider
population
and we can begin to get back to okay you
know some semblance of normality over
the course of the year
okay uh yougov poll saying that
two-thirds are likely to take
the vaccine if offered which means a
third uh are not
likely to um the health secretary was
pressed on that
yesterday at the news conference at
number 10. and he
wouldn't go as far as to say whether or
not it would be compulsory to take a
vaccine do you think it should be
we're not in favor of making it
compulsory we don't have a history of
that in this country
what we want to do is win the argument
and educate people
and persuade them that taking the
vaccine is the right thing for them
and their family of course there has
been a recent history in this country of
those people
spreading misinformation about some
vaccines so there's work to be done
by the government by healthcare
professionals to win that argument but i
very much hope that we will do and
certainly i would advise
anybody to do so i'd advise my own
elderly parents to take
the vaccine if it's available to them
and i'd take it myself at the right time
when it's available to me okay so i
think that's the best approach to be
honest
rather than forcing people to take a
vaccine against their will
okay health secretary top tip don't call
your mother elderly on the telly
seriously um she'll have something to
say about that later on um
are you um as far as evolution
is concerned is it a disaster
no it's not and that's that's not what
the prime minister was saying the prime
minister's always supported
devolution um but he is at heart a
unionist
and he is very troubled by the rise of
nationalism and separatism
in the form of nicolas sturgeon and the
snp and that i think is the comment that
he was making
yesterday that uh whilst in some parts
of the
united kingdom devolution has enabled
local people to have greater say of
their own destinies to make different
and
the right decisions for their
communities one of the downsides in
scotland
has been that it's it's been misused by
the snp to drive a wedge
between people who are ultimately part
of the same country with hundreds of
years
of history of friendship and partnership
and the pm is very concerned by that
and you can see that in the actions that
the government's been doing whether it's
the
um uk internal market bill that's
currently going through parliament
which sets out to strengthen the union
to make it easier
and more certain for goods and services
and people to travel
around the union those are the sorts of
things this government's going to do
to strengthen the united kingdom in the
years ahead
uh he used the word disaster and he said
that it was tony blair's biggest mistake
well the disaster that the prime
minister is referring to is the rise of
separatism
and nationalism in the form of the snp
any of us who love the
united kingdom who believe that we
should stay together that we're much
stronger as a
as one union uh believes that it's very
disheartening to see people trying to
to break up the union trying to take any
opportunity to sow
uh dissent and grievance where there is
none and the prime minister is
absolutely
determined as is the whole government to
keep the union together and to do
everything possible
to persuade our friends and neighbours
in scotland
that they are better off you know um
to remain within the united kingdom and
that's that is the the mission of the
government in the years ahead
um are you proud of scotland and wales
having their own parliaments
well it was a i think it's a choice of
it was a very long time ago it was you
know i was a teenager when that happened
this was a choice
uh by the people of uh scotland and
wales and northern ireland they
democratically chose
to do that and i completely support that
we as a united kingdom government work
extremely
closely with them um i work although my
department is predominantly
focused on england in terms of housing
communities and local government i work
with
opposite numbers and partners in the
devolved administrations and
will continue to do so the government is
trying to support them through
coronavirus you see that with some of
the big initiatives
that we've done like the furlough scheme
which is for the whole of the united
kingdom like the purchase of vaccines
uh where we're doing it for the whole
united kingdom and that's absolutely
right what i i don't like to see okay is
the leaders of some of the devolved
administrations i mean principally
scotland
trying to find opportunities to drive us
apart i think that's
deeply unhelpful i've never been
attracted to separatism or narrow
nationalism i think we should all fight
against that
you say that they democratically chose
to have their own parliaments what about
if they want to democratically choose
whether or not to be
more independent
well that that that would also be uh be
a choice for the
the scottish the welsh or the northern
irish people i would strongly
campaign against that if that was the
case i don't see there's a
realistic prospect of that because we've
had a referendum
in scotland and nicola sturgeon and alex
salmond the then leader
of the snp said that was a once in a
generation
opportunity which passed and should be
laid to rest for for many years i can't
for the life of me see that now would be
a sensible time as i think gordon brown
said earlier
in the week to be reopening those
questions at the moment
the whole of the united kingdom should
be focused on beating this virus
and our economic recovery because
millions of people's jobs
and livelihoods depend on the actions
that we as the united kingdom government
can make and the developed
administrations can make themselves but
we are infinitely stronger together as a
united kingdom
the power of the uk treasury for example
has been
very clear throughout this virus in the
way it's been able to support millions
of people's jobs in scotland as it has
in
england and the rest of the united
kingdom but what about if the people of
scotland and or wales want to
democratically choose otherwise
well i think if your question is should
there be a a second referendum in
scotland then
my answer is i don't think that this is
the right time to do that
uh the leaders of the s b themselves
only a couple of years ago said they
should be settled for
a generation and as i say any politician
who wants to spend
time on questions like that at the
moment
when we're in the biggest health crisis
since you know
for for generations and we're facing a
very very significant
period of economic disruption i think is
you know is frankly deluding themselves
they should be focusing on the
priorities of the public
yeah i suppose nicolas sturgeon might
say the same thing about brexit but
she's not on the show today so
i can't ask her what i can do is ask you
about
social housing tell me more well thanks
kate we
after the grenfell tragedy uh my
predecessors
and i in government worked with some of
the survivors
and the bereaved of grenfell to think
about how
we can put in place much stronger
regulation for the four million
households living in social housing
because there was a real sense that
people's genuine concerns had been
ignored
that they hadn't been treated with
dignity and respect
by their landlords and that people in
social housing were somehow
different to those in the private rental
sector or homeowners and we wanted to
change that so
today we're publishing the fruit of a
long period of hard work
the social housing white paper which
sets out a much
stronger and tougher consumer regulation
for people living in social housing
whether that's through housing
associations
uh or other social landlords like local
councils
so if you have concerns you can raise
them your voice can be heard
and you can get proper address and that
should mean in the years ahead
better quality service safer
accommodation
for people living in social housing i
think that's a really important
step forwards okay
safer accommodation just uh while i've
got you i know you have to dash housing
secretary
but what about um a word for the uh
families and survivors
of those that were caught up in the
grenfell disaster yesterday it emerged
that fire tests were rigged
rigged in relation to material used
on the building well i watched some of
the
testimony last night from the
former employee of the manufacturer of
that product and i have to say it was
very
very shocking to hear an individual
admitting
that the fire safety test was actually
rigged on
a very important material used on the
building
i i will have to learn more as the
inquiry
goes on as to whether that was a one-off
or something that was more
widespread within the sector but my view
is that building safety
regulation and standards in this country
have been far too
poor for too long and we need to
decisively change that
we will next year be legislating through
our new building safety
bill for the largest most significant
change in building safety
laws for about 40 years and of course
there's a huge amount of work now to do
to remediate buildings
uh particularly tall buildings like uh
grenfell tower which have got materials
on them which need to come off
so that people can feel safe at home we
are making progress on that
around 80 percent of the buildings that
have the grenfell style
cladding on them have now either had it
remediated or there are workers on site
today
beginning that work but there's a lot
more to do